ok se ne va in mezzo agli armadietti c'è
un passaggio segreto
no per ora no sei tu gucci lord no sono
questo però è questo ebbene gucci lord e
con la maglia della nike non ha capito
niente ha dato la prima volta che mostro
il mio avatar vi dirò blocks ma è
bellissimo
non è un po troppo quasi dice che un po
eccessiva è un po di storage ovvero è sì
forse a me ammazzano per primo ok quindi
io a voi non vi devo dire cosa siamo
è vero dobbiamo dire ognuno per sé anche
se vorrei sapere cosa stia per incuria
ripetitivi di ognuno
allora gli innocenti devono solo
nascondersi lo sceriffo deve capire chi
è l'assassino e ammazzarlo è l'assassino
deve ammazzare tutti senza essere
ammazzato dallo sceriffo giustamente
quindi per tensione non stare in
vicoletti la prima volta con lui magari
finisce in un vicoletto da solo con
qualcuno e viene uccisa mi fermo un
innocente novecento nel novecento un
innocente ti prego a fun to sorella
vabbè la tranche da innocente vivai e
caduff ritengo vada concentrato e niente
mi nascondo mi concentro nelle belle
nascondere ma ok che voglio vedere un
bel nascondiglio darà però io la gente
la odio quindi non ci sto vicino aiuto a
chi è chi è cosa non muscoloso quello
muscoloso va bene di nuovo lui come
capitata nulla sull'innocente queste due
volte che l'assassino
allora ragazzi tranquilli che era
incontro per abbracciarlo dai teatri
come fate solo posso dire se lui se lo
sceriffo tu si ferma qua lo voglio dire
perché siete degli infami
e tieni a pistola pronta ma in prima
persona perché così è più facile sparare
e preparati aiuto continua a coltivare
call of duty
grazie grazie a tutti
ok sceriffo no vabbè ragazzi davvero
bella secondo me ho messo una roba è una
roba che mi fa uscire sempre sceriffo io
sono ancora io ve lo giuro incredibile e
la sta rubando a fare il ruolo non ha
mai fatto nulla ma non ho fatto nulla so
sempre innocente occhio occhi occhio
pecchiamo un bel nascondiglio parlatemi
parlate parlate allora vieni qua venica
venica per un muscoloso non può essere
sempre così ho capito come si spara
quindi almeno siamo a posto così com'è
in mezzo agli armadietti c'è un
passaggio segreto
no per ora no
era lui mori il dottore in nove solo
agli oscar
dove sono gli oscar datemi gli oscar per
cui si lanciano i coltelli
c'era una volta io ho visto proprio
fidata ciecamente li sa che non funziona
come sia stata una volta tasto destro
tech sono estranei a quelli che non
sanno chi sono non lo sanno
esatto acid puoi nascondere certo anche
se basta guardare in faccia male rendo
ragazzi presenti ha detto corre
ma cosa parla spararmi se sono girati
dall'altra parte ma incedibile sceriffi
veri ma come è possibile che try harder
2005 2005 caro ho capito come come spara
così mentre corre non sono ok già pronti
siamo va bene lì quando si può andare
no faccio un tizio nel carro armato lì è
però non possiamo andare a dividere la
mappa stessi un passaggio segreto vieni
vieni veni veni veni veni già qui col
fumo ci vedono poco e male però no di
qua non si può andare lipidico di verona
ne vorrà del tempo
vinciamo e l'assassino è ok e non ha
ammazzato tutti abbiamo vinto esatto se
troviamo un bel nascondiglio
abbiamo vinto in automatico però è
chiaro non vedo grandi cose sai com'è e
poi soprattutto c'è un problema aerei
pure sceriffo povero cucciolo è
veramente la persona più odiosa del
mondo quindi sceriffo ok mi ci gioco è
una costola che fare con tata perché è
rimasta zitta che mi vesto sì al 19
detto che c'è di forte io elettro
sceriffo non è così solo scifo io faccio
vedere la pistola non mi fido più dei
cedibili affascinato di essere lo
sceriffo stesso noci ripoli la fatalità
la scherzando l'unico i due qualcosa io
non mi voglio più vedere tanto non ci
abbiamo il tempo noi che siamo innocenti
no andarsene altezze un tempo di estate
non lo so è che sembra di nuovo fare
anche a me perché all'inizio del iii
sceriffo quindi invece sono io l'ho
visto
non sono i ragazzi io gente che mi sta
seguendo ciò ha paura incredibile quello
giro non sono io stavolta non aveva lo
so che qualcuno di voi è qualcosa però
non so chi io so lo sceriffo numero vi
siete dichiarati
allora io non sono spariti che sparare
quello biondo questa bionda pino il
biondo il maschio ma sicuro oggi si sa
mai potrebbe essere stesso il killer
uniti stadi non ha del tutto fare ancora
no non lo era
porca miseria capita no non lo sono
finiti sono imbecilli scusami eh sono in
bici mi ha detto che spara spara fammi
salire a metà le sole dita cena
bellissima la metà linee brava si è
fatta da gente innocente anche io
innocente
mettila credo si sia h troppo agli altri
un killer allora per innocente e l'app
ne son sicuro tocca temi oggi mania
se lo sceriffo sta sparando di impararlo
ma chi te lo sci rivelato a sparare non
so perché ma perché è matto avviate
ferie o tifavi lo ha prima vi ma perché
vai solo un brutto sarà per questo
ancora beh è un pazzo e un biondino
pazzo queste morti
vabbè ma se spara quello sbagliato staff
è stato eliminato quindi è però talmente
scarso che gli manca capito normale nel
tuo caso ci sono cascato sapevo lo
sapevo io lo sapevo qua lo sapevo che
era lei
sono caduto l'ho visto ho detto non può
essere lei non può essere lei era lei la
mia vita fa schifo adesso ho contato
sono gigante quindi uno se mi spara mi
prende molto più facilmente ed a 0 0
ma perde anche difficile da nascondere
se un peso cavolo di ne va bè ragazzi
c'è una mia sono un amico che guarda
perché non ci stai perché si trova così
faccio il tuo dai io me ne vado con gli
scatoloni da sempre tanto che si vede da
qua no non ti vediamo la serie vero sei
troppo grande che schifo inutile la
sentiamo cosa vuoi mi piace mangiare ma
cerchiamo di scoprire dove l'assassino e
credo sia di sotto con maniere los que
no perché quello è quello che la pistola
ma sono usciti prove dove siete scusa
tutto su quali dov'è di inseguimento 20
poi non lo vedono qua e pulse scendiamo
le scale lo troviamo ma dai ma basta
perché ritengono le imboscate
basta
i topi schifosi con il coltello che
fastidio innocente
va bene innocente uno bello sto posto
però sono parole inutili molto bello sto
posto che non conosco io voglio non
correre in faccia a qualcuno che il
primo google rinfaccia muoio io allora
questo è un passaggio segreto della
gente simile perché non cercherebbe così
passaggi segreti sicuro vecchi la mi fai
paura gara clonazione la scherzando
allora ti ho visto l'ho visto
l'assassino dove centra uno biondo buffa
ma ti pare un lay the street boys dato
sia uguale calda a quello biondo dei
backstreet boys i denti ma io mi sto
eccolo vedo tornasse possono sparare
anche attraverso i vetri dello sceriffo
cosa quando vedo distruggere la quale
c'e no volevo dire sono i killer
dell'assassino volume giorno per fare
ragazza e pasta è stato berni piaciuta e
molto più bella dell'altra perché
ve la dico riforme c'è tanta gente è
fatta bene non c'è niente da dire era
quindi la voglia di fare assolutamente
vi piace la mappa ragazzi volete che la
rifaccio schietto nei commenti se la
risposta è no non me ne frega niente la
rifarò lo stesso
grazie di essere stati incidenti nella
mia scelta
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
ringrazio step e feres aver partecipato
a questo video ringrazio entrambi per
avermi ammazzato a tradimento si parla
plastici vi dedico la pasta che ho come
sfondo la vedi sia piaciuto non mi piace
che vari social comino dalla descrizione
iscrivetevi e mettete anche la
campanella che vi arrivano le notifiche
dei video e noi ci vediamo proseguito
belle ragazze